esto significa que tenemos esta estructura química
en la superficie de nuestras células sanguíneas:
tres azúcares simples unidos que dan lugar a un azúcar complejo.
Y esto, se define como grupo sanguíneo del tipo O.
Ahora, ¿cuántos tienen el grupo sanguíneo A?
Aquí mismo.
Esto significa que tienen una enzima en sus células
que añade una pieza más,
esa azúcar roja,
para crear una estructura más compleja.
Y ¿cuántos son del tipo B?
Unos cuantos.
Su enzima es algo distinta de la del tipo A,
por lo que la estructura es algo diferente,
y aquellos que sean del tipo AB
tienen una enzima de su madre, y la otra de su padre,
y así sus estructuras están prácticamente balanceadas.
Cuando esto se descubrió,
ya en el siglo pasado,
permitió uno de los procesos médicos más importantes en el mundo,
se trata, por supuesto, de la transfusión sanguínea.
Y conociendo el grupo sanguíneo,
podemos tener claro, si necesitara una transfusión
que el donante pertenece al mismo grupo sanguíneo,
para que el organismo no se tope con azúcares desconocidos,
que no le gustarían y probablemente rechazaría.
¿Qué más quieren decirnos los azúcares de la superficie de las células?
Esos azúcares podrían estar diciéndonos que tenemos cáncer.
Entonces, hace algunas décadas,
las correlaciones comenzaron a surgir del análisis de tejido tumoral.
Y el escenario típico es un paciente con un tumor detectado,
y el tejido se elimina con un procedimiento de biopsia
y luego se envía a un laboratorio de patología
donde ese tejido se analiza para buscar cambios químicos
que pueden informar al oncólogo sobre el mejor curso de tratamiento.
En estudios como ese se descubrió
que los azúcares cambian
si la célula pasa de estar sana a estar enferma.
Y esas correlaciones han surgido una y otra y otra vez.
Pero una gran pregunta en el campo ha sido: ¿Por qué?
¿Por qué los cánceres tienen diferentes azúcares? ¿Qué importancia tiene eso?
¿Por qué sucede y qué podemos hacer al respecto si resulta que
esto está relacionado con el proceso de la enfermedad?
Entonces, uno de los cambios que estudiamos
es un aumento en la densidad de un azúcar en particular
eso se llama ácido siálico.
Y creo que este será uno de los azúcares más importantes
de nuestros tiempos,
por eso aliento a todos a familiarizarse con esta palabra.
El ácido siálico no es el tipo de azúcar que ingerimos.
Son azúcares diferentes.
Este es un tipo de azúcar que en realidad se encuentra
en ciertos niveles en todas las células del cuerpo.
En realidad, es bastante común en las células.
Pero por alguna razón,
las células cancerosas, al menos en una enfermedad progresiva,
tienden a tener más ácido siálico
del que tendría una célula normal y saludable.
¿Por qué?
¿Qué significa eso?
Bueno, hemos aprendido
que tiene que ver con el sistema inmune.
Así les explicaré algo sobre la importancia del sistema inmune
en el cáncer.
Y esto es algo que se oye, creo, mucho en las noticias estos días.
La gente está comenzando a familiarizarse con el término
"inmunoterapia contra el cáncer".
Y algunos de Uds. incluso podrían conocer a personas
que se están beneficiando de estas muy nuevas formas de tratar el cáncer.
Ahora sabemos que las células inmunes,
que son los glóbulos blancos que recorren el torrente sanguíneo,
nos protegen a diario de cosas que salieron mal,
incluido el cáncer.
En esta imagen,
esas pequeñas bolas verdes son las células inmunes,
y esa gran célula rosa es una célula cancerosa.
Y estas células inmunes circulan y prueban todas las células del cuerpo.
Ese es su trabajo.
Y la mayoría de las veces, las células saben bien.
Pero de vez en cuando, una célula puede tener mal sabor.
Con suerte, esa es la célula cancerosa,
y cuando esas células inmunes prueban el mal sabor,
lanzan un ataque total y matan esas células.
Eso lo sabemos.
También sabemos que si se potencia esa cata,
si se alientan esas células inmunes a que den una gran mordida
de una célula cancerosa,
uno se autoprotege mejor del cáncer todos los días
y tal vez se cure un cáncer.
Y ahora hay un par de fármacos en el mercado
que se usan para tratar a pacientes con cáncer
que actúa exactamente mediante este proceso.
Activan el sistema inmune
para que sea más vigoroso
para protegernos del cáncer.
De hecho, uno de esos fármacos
bien puede haber salvado la vida del presidente Jimmy Carter.
¿Recuerdan que el presidente Carter tenía un melanoma maligno
que había hecho metástasis en su cerebro?
Y ese diagnóstico suele ir acompañado del pronóstico
"meses de vida".
Pero a él le trataron con uno de estos fármacos nuevos inmunoestimulantes,
y ahora su melanoma parece estar en remisión,
lo que es notable,
teniendo en cuenta la situación solo hace unos años.
De hecho, es tan notable
que provocan afirmaciones como esta:
"El cáncer vive un momento de penicilina",
con estos nuevos medicamentos de inmunoterapia.
Quiero decir, es increíblemente audaz decir eso sobre una enfermedad
que hemos estado combatiendo durante mucho tiempo
y contra la que muchas veces hemos perdido la batalla.
Esto es muy emocionante.
Ahora, ¿qué tiene esto que ver con los azúcares?
Bueno, les diré lo que hemos aprendido.
Cuando una célula inmune se acurruca contra una célula cancerosa para probar,
está buscando signos de enfermedad,
y si encuentra esos signos,
la célula se activa y lanza un misil que mata a la célula.
Pero si esa célula cancerosa tiene un bosque denso de ese azúcar, ácido siálico,
bueno, comienza a tener muy buen sabor.
Hay una proteína en las células inmunes que toma el ácido siálico,
y si esa proteína se mantiene en esa sinapsis
entre la célula inmune y la célula cancerosa,
hace dormir a esa célula inmune.
Los ácidos siálicos dicen a la célula inmune:
"Oye, esta célula está bien. No hay nada que ver aquí, vete,
busca en otro lado".
Entonces en otras palabras,
mientras las células tengan una gruesa capa de ácido siálico,
se ven fabulosas, ¿verdad?
Es asombroso.
¿Y si se pudiera quitar esa capa
y extraer ese azúcar?
Entonces, el sistema inmune
podría identificar esa célula cancerosa por lo que realmente es:
algo que necesita ser destruido.
Y esto es lo que hacemos en mi laboratorio.
Estamos desarrollando nuevos medicamentos
que son básicamente cortadoras de césped de superficie celular.
Moléculas que bajan a la superficie de estas células cancerosas
y cortan esos ácidos siálicos,
para que el sistema inmune pueda alcanzar su máximo potencial
en la eliminación de esas células cancerígenas del cuerpo.
Por tanto, concluyendo,
les recuerdo nuevamente:
las células están cubiertas con azúcares.
Los azúcares dicen a las células alrededor de esa célula
si la célula es buena o mala.
Y eso es importante,
porque el sistema inmune necesita mantener solo las células buenas.
De lo contrario, tendríamos enfermedades autoinmunes.
Pero, de vez en cuando, los cánceres tienen la capacidad
de expresar estos nuevos azúcares.
Y ahora que entendemos
cómo esos azúcares hipnotizan al sistema inmune,
podemos inventar nuevos medicamentos para despertar a esas células inmunes,
y decirles: "Ignora los azúcares, come la célula,
y ten una deliciosa merienda, con sabor a cáncer".
Gracias.
(Aplausos)